[Music]
all right so we're back and I I know
we're running out of time Kelly so all
hosti this one um oh this is the one I
wanted the most time for okay good we
spend all day all right go ahead all
right so this is the 500th episode which
still blows my mind I think it's like
the drumroll moment to give everybody
the dirt what's it like to live and be
in the ecosystem
of kind of a
Maniac husband who's a YouTuber and
who's what's it like to live with John
thought that was the first question no
that's like living with somebody with
ADHD you just did a very good coaching
move and you said like I don't know ADHD
but I know my husband like that okay
yeah so behind closed doors we've
established I'm messy yeah and can I say
there's a difference between messy and
gross yeah I'm not gross
no but I am messy
yes yes so I will just defend you on the
not gross thing okay good um I'm overly
hygienic I think yes you are I I could
share that um your skincare routine is
something to behold and it always has
been that predates even our dating I
think I dated one of my first
girlfriends who told me I would be
handsome if I didn't have such bad skin
and it just locked into my soul yeah it
did all those voices um so you know the
weekly face mask and the rolly I don't
even know what all of our Tools in our
bathroom do I just know that they're
yours and it didn't occur to me till I
was in my 40s that I should wash my face
every night so I'm 63 and look how good
I look just kidding yeah um so that's
there's that um can I talk about
grilling you can talk about it it's
embarrassing John is a novice griller
I'm embarrassing when it comes to it and
I don't know why like you get so
embarrassed about this this is one of
those things it doesn't bother you until
people come over and I'm the one at the
grill with the burgers or the steak or
whatever and then I see it wash over you
and I just think
why good at this multiple you're the
best state cooker I've ever met ever
it's incredible and there's been
multiple usually Texas males but there
occasional Texas males Tennessee males
who are like hey why is your wife
grilling it's like well because she's
awesome and I don't know how and it's
this look of like hey why are you with
that woman and it's like because I'm
cheating on my wife it's it' be very
similar just that look of disdain
and how dare you man like you let us all
down I mean you can't be good at
everything and you know so things don't
know how to cook in general I'm not good
when you been trying we eat was it Hank
and dead mush yeah just opening a few
cans and adding them to ground beef and
eggs yeah into a bowl yeah Hank would
call it Hank and dead mush it was
fantastic the name of
it all right so I can't cook and I've
got an elaborate skincare routine what
else I'm late allegedly You Dropped a
baton in high school that was the first
story I ever heard from your friends
about you and they have probably still
not let it go cuz I didn't drop it it
was that's how far back I have to go to
have dirt like I feel like you probably
knowing
how I'm pretty open about your voices
that tell you how you're horrible I have
a feeling everyone's heard everything
you said something while we were walking
going on our weekly walks last
week that when we were talking about
this I was asking if you're nervous or
not and you said I just want people to
know you're not as good as they think
that that you are yeah you're not as
good and you're not as bad yeah like I
think and that may be just the curse of
any public
person like Instagram can make things
look a certain way and you're probably
not that smart or that in tuned or that
whatever I don't know I don't follow you
on Instagram
um but probably you're not that good at
whatever it is but also you're not that
bad so whatever the critics are saying
or the comments are lobbing I I don't
know again but or however bad you say
that you are about things you're not
that bad either like I don't miss
appointments I'm 5 minutes late to
everything yeah you're a good guy who's
trying really hard sometimes you miss
but you're always trying but as Yoda
says that's not enough you're a regular
person I don't do Star Wars that's true
last thing what's your favorite thing
about people coming up to us while we're
having dinner together um when they walk
away I thought it was going to be when
they told me how wonderful I am and they
they put their hand up to your face like
hold on I know you in the middle of
something romantic but no I again I'm
getting more used to it and having to do
my own like why does that bother me so
much mostly I like to go through life
unnoticed so here I am look how much
work I've done um this is a lot of this
is years of therapy this is way to go
Holly way to go Hol um yeah so yeah I
still don't love it yeah and I
appreciate so much that they want to
acknowledge you and that they want to
like show gratitude or even share like
some impact you've had I love that I
just wish I didn't have to be part of it
which is why people may notice like I
thought your wife was here I have to go
to the bathroom she's in the parking lot
that's right yeah so I I don't love it
and I do appreciate it a while ago when
we were sitting down across this is
years ago sitting down saying like if
we're going to stay married we have to
like rebuild this thing from the floor
up and I remember as a part of that
series of conversations we had one of
the things I said that like it was so
embarrassing for me at the time I was
just so humiliated embarrassed but it
was like can you just tell me you're
proud of me and as I've I've gotten my
own therapy shout out Holly way to go
same therapist incredible as I've
gotten Weller if you will
MH I've begun to see that
everywhere like I begun to see that
what's that you do love me and that you
know as Berne Brown says whatever you go
looking for that's what you're going to
find and I was looking for all the ways
I was coming up short and I missed
how all those ways he was you were
wrestling with your own stuff and at the
same time saying no no no I'm really I'm
really proud of
you one day um when I was working at
Belmont I come racing home for lunch and
i' forgotten
something and I grabbed something to eat
but i' had forgotten something and then
I kissed you and as I was leaving the
door I mean leaving the house you said
you must be amazing at your job and I
stopped and dropped my shoulders and I
was
like she sees it but there's more she
sees
it and you said you followed up with cuz
you're such a disaster in every facet of
your life you must be so good when you
just get there and plug in and I
remember
thinking hey that's very true like I
think that all the other places I've
worked they put up with kind of the
maniacal whatever because when it went
down I was really good when it went down
and it was like got to fix the budget
someone's going to take their life like
delone will show up and he'll kill he'll
just do a great job but we got to deal
with all this drumming going on over
here but it really was a turning point
like what
if I tried to be less of a disaster in
every part of my life and showed up
would it make showing up better and I
think over the last three to five years
I've proven that to myself that um kind
of like the artist it's like I got to do
drugs so I can write good songs then
they get sober and they realize their
songs are great U they're actually
better and clearer and their shows are
better um I don't know that was an
important moment for
me both you recognizing like you must be
good at your job
and man you're hard to be around but
that's also how I experience you in a
carage like it's like what I was saying
I'll put up with the piles because all
the other stuff is so great and in the
stuff that really
matters you show up and you do a good
job you're a good dad and all that good
stuff all that good stuff but you're a
mess that's the trade I'm willing to
make a mess holistically yes yeah you're
consistent I'm consistent hey I love you
thank you for being my friend love you
thanks for uh for being married to me
and for coming Out of the Woods being on
the internets now forever forever yes
yeah don't make me regret it already and
you're beautiful thanks we won't regret
it thanks your skin looks
[Laughter]
good thank you love you're
welcome